what it does drain god i swear veso hey
man i need y'all to check me out on a
bullet care podcast [ __ ] train guard
hey
podcast special guest man the homie
detroit's finest i swear vezo in the
building man thank god what it do
welcome welcome welcome man appreciate
you brother yes sir first of all
congratulations man the glow up since
you left motown has been glorious yes
sir absolutely
now i stopped grinding back to back you
know what i'm saying it's just like
[ __ ] independence so that [ __ ]
like having having having your first
child or getting your first apartment or
your first house
it's crazy because
like when you were assigned to a
quote-unquote major right you got out
you know you you did the major [ __ ] you
ran around you know i i but it's like i
feel like
somehow it held you back absolutely
because i wasn't doing the [ __ ] that i
wanted to do
and just i feel like
you know
one thing about it every artist know
what's best for them
that's the thing that's what labels
managers my [ __ ] pr everybody gotta
understand that about artists we know
what's best for us we know what we want
we know what worked for us we pay
attention to ourselves more than anybody
do so you got to think we're dealing
with a major you basically going to a
[ __ ] who from the outside
looking in and like all right you should
do this you should you know what i mean
it's like telling somebody that's like
somebody who didn't raise you telling
you what's best for you as a adult
like you got to where you were
by doing something and it's almost like
once you then you then you get on board
with a major and then they want to
they're asking you to stop doing what
got you there and logically it don't
make sense because like what i've been
doing i obviously got y'all
interested
in the first place we stopped doing what
got you all attention
it'll make sense you know i mean i feel
like the labels should just give input
pay for the [ __ ] they need to pay for
and do the bigger level [ __ ]
and let us let you run let us run let us
handle our music and the way we want to
market ourselves those [ __ ]
ain't doing no dumb [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying that's all that matters yeah
i feel like since you got not made like
you like you said nothing's holding you
back you've been just dropping nonstop
and that's really
that's what i mean you're one of the
hottest artists in the game right now
and that's based on
you absolutely your work ethic your
output that freedom that freedom is like
man this [ __ ] don't cost me nothing
mm-hmm feel me like uh right you know i
i handle my business with the producer
so
that that process is easy you know what
i'm saying we got social media which is
free instagram ain't charging no monthly
fee that [ __ ] is free you feel me so
it's like
my just even having my youtube free so
ain't no point in holding nothing
[ __ ] is all free well i'm gonna sit on
this [ __ ] and think too hard about it
folks overthink it we overthinking you
[ __ ] people overthink [ __ ] way too much
if if they don't like it do some emotion
just drop some more and that's just a
piece of more piece of your independent
catalog you can't lose fans from
dropping too much music you lose fans
from doing dumb goofy [ __ ] or you lose
fans from sitting on your hands too long
and then they forget about you
consist is key do you feel like you had
to win some fans back absolutely i had
to win all my fans with
every single one of them [ __ ]
all of them i feel like they stopped
believing that i was hungry
and i was hungry in the [ __ ] you feel
me like [ __ ] starving like i want this
[ __ ] but and they mind just me moving on
that major level and doing [ __ ] that i
really didn't align with
you feel me made i feel like how this
[ __ ] made it you know when people hear
you got a record deal that's like
hearing a [ __ ] just went to the nba or
the nfl
you feel me so they automatically feel
like
all right he made it you know what i'm
saying so
yeah most definitely i had to get all my
fans back yeah i think like i think that
that also is like a myth that's finally
sort of like slowly going away early but
surely yeah because a lot of artists
like
it's a is a the biggest mistake they
could ever make is signed into a major
label and they making that [ __ ] vocal
you know i mean a lot of artists being
real vocal about
not going to no major how important it
is to have independency and you know
move and be hands on with your [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying so definitely that
that's that thing kind of going out the
window you mentioned um
obviously handling everything within
your team in-house yourself
working with the producers yourself
figuring figuring out how to get them
situated yourself so
how what's the distro is it tunecore is
it distrokid is it like how are you
doing the distro foundation media shout
out to shout out to the homie lee shout
out to lee lee solid yeah all the way up
and down just 100 like he understand
it ain't no ain't never no debate it
ain't never no
argument or no back and forth he don't
try he's like listen man that's what you
want to do with doing it
[ __ ] it like he feel like how we feel
about it what we got to lose
all he said stay consistent keep putting
that [ __ ] out stay consistent with his
music so he get it that's the only way
to man cause you know if you think about
like
your lane right it's a very crowded lane
for [ __ ] so like and so you you in order
for you to stand out you gotta do the
most you gotta keep pressing pressing
press and play practice i ain't no
antics type person like i ain't with the
antics and the gimmicks like i don't do
like goofy [ __ ] goofy lame man [ __ ] i
don't do i don't not be myself i don't
get on the internet posting guns and
[ __ ] like i'm a real street [ __ ] i
really come from that you got [ __ ]
that start rapping and they try to run
to the streets you got real street
[ __ ] that start rapping and leave from
that [ __ ] like
them [ __ ] going now i'm going here
y'all go ahead all right i know i know
what all that's about
go ahead you feel me i ain't with none
of that lame ass [ __ ] i ain't with no i
ain't doing no rap b for no [ __ ] i'm
not doing no all that this i'm not doing
none of that [ __ ] with nothing with
nobody i ain't with none of that so for
me it's just strictly music that's all i
that's all i can provide to the rap game
is music what's that wasn't it was that
hard for you because obviously detroit
at the moment is one of the more popping
scenes in hip-hop so and i do feel like
right now at least it seems as if
everyone who's popping out the city for
the most part are kind of moving
in the same direction as to where
in the past it felt like there was a lot
of
friction
between a lot of the popping artists in
detroit as to where now you know i know
it's different sides of town but you
know between yourself babyface ray pedro
giovanni peasy you know uh
rio the young og who's obviously from
flynn i believe right
um i just feel like it seems like
detroit whether or not y'all are like
hanging out together yeah that's not
what i'm saying it just seems like
there's a movement it's an understanding
for sure and and it seems like it's at
least in a respectful way as opposed to
you know because i feel like that might
kind of been the issue with detroit in
the past i know it was it was it was the
friction it was the mis understanding
the lack of communication you know what
i mean like i don't think that
some of the brothers before us
felt as if it was enough money for
everybody we get it we know it's enough
money for every [ __ ] body like
and we all got the same
content basically we rap about the same
[ __ ] we rap on the same beats down there
like and if ain't the same we still
talking about the same [ __ ] just in
different ways
and and everybody's succeeding at it so
that just show you it's enough
money it's enough opportunity it's
enough listeners and followers for every
[ __ ] body everybody in detroit rap
scene got a relationship somehow some
way
everybody know each other some [ __ ]
might talk to might not talk to the next
[ __ ] or something you heard some [ __ ]
entourage may not however it is it's
still a understanding like we not gonna
embarrass this [ __ ] though we ain't
gonna make
anybody look bad for the scene we all
feel like that for you did you have to
get past like that mentality ever
because like obviously you got locked up
you know there's no question in what
what you know your credibility in the
streets and [ __ ] but it feels like
you're
all the way in on this rap [ __ ] and i
feel like that is the difference because
sometimes man like
you can't be nine toes in the rap [ __ ]
and one toe back in the street [ __ ]
that's why i went to the fest you know
what i'm saying so like
what what what did it take for you to
get mentally past that mind state where
you you know
gave a [ __ ] about the petty [ __ ] or
would participate in a certain share or
let maybe [ __ ] that would bother you
maybe five years ago not bother you
anymore it took for me to lose
absolutely everything i had
it took for me to lose people that i
love
it took for me to lose opportunity i
literally went flat the [ __ ] broke you
know what i'm saying i had hundreds of
thousands like we need to talk about no
amount or no i don't need one [ __ ] had
some paper so
you know i lost a lot of [ __ ] and i it
took it took that for me to understand
how pride really worked and how
you know understanding work how
self-preservation work you know what i
mean
it took for me to to
it took for that for me to understand
that i'm a man i don't even [ __ ] with no
[ __ ] thinking about me
i already got i got an old lady i don't
know i don't care what no i'm i'm not
you heard i rock i rock that way so i
don't [ __ ] what a [ __ ] think about me
but it took for all it took all that for
me to understand that and the moment i
got that understanding [ __ ] elevated for
me financially i got more money than i
ever had i never i never i always knew i
would have this type of paper but i just
didn't really see it
i never had the type of money i got
especially like
being like [ __ ] was hustling i thought
i was rich back then i got real money
now i mean now you got something to lose
right i mean not to say you never had
that to lose before because you lost it
already but now you know it could be it
could be gone that i have i didn't know
what i had to lose until i lost that
[ __ ] that's like losing a good [ __ ] and
you ain't know she was a good one too it
was too late and another [ __ ] get it
and i'll show you how to have her you
heard like you know what i'm saying so
yeah like i got a lot of [ __ ] to lose i
got the same thing to lose now that i
had then
it's just i appreciate it moving on i
had family then i had a child then
i had a rap career then i had businesses
then right i lost that [ __ ] i didn't
appreciate it i appreciate that [ __ ] now
nah i think like you know like i said
man
it is it it's clear you're doing better
than you've ever been but you got the
blinders on
yeah and you working hard i mean man
you're working your ass off talk to me
about
rich off pints the first one obviously a
huge i mean the sequel's coming out
tomorrow
but
that project i think really solidified a
lot for you i i think it did too that
[ __ ] went up i wasn't even expecting it
like that was around when i dropped
richard pike's two that was that point
where that was the first project i
dropped when i
left motown
and that's when i said you know what i
don't i'm i'm only making music for me
i'm making a [ __ ] that i'm gonna listen
to when i get in my car i want to listen
to the [ __ ] that i want to listen to on
the plane like because i'm looking
forward to for other [ __ ] to make the
music that that that can motivate me
i say you know i motivate my
[ __ ] so so that was the record
where i stopped overthink that was that
album i stopped overthinking and i
started having fun with that [ __ ] and i
think that's why the outcome was what it
was so i really learned to
don't don't don't don't overthink it and
not be in it for for certain [ __ ] like
i'm not in this [ __ ] for money no for no
more and at that time i ain't had what i
got right now financially so you know
[ __ ] ain't get some money and then be
like no i ain't working for the money i
wouldn't i ain't had no real paper then
you know i went in the streets
but when i dropped richard planks too
you know it was all still rap money yeah
so it was just
that that [ __ ] taught me a lot just
moving that way not being in [ __ ] for
money and stream almost like yeah like
when you when you do things
and the motive is i'm chasing a hit or
i'm chasing whatever is happening i
think this is what's going to work on
spotify
that [ __ ] for the most part never works
out but when you just
stay true to yourself motive genuine you
always win i just learned that i learned
that [ __ ] with experience because i feel
like there was like you know when you
were on motown it felt like
you know you come up to the mixer
meeting a couple times and it's almost
like we got to chase a hit so these
[ __ ] will let me drop music
yeah would like [ __ ] yeah i was i was
exactly what it was i gotta hurry up and
get these folks they want so i can
do me i was chasing the hit i was in
that [ __ ] for success i was in that [ __ ]
to to take care of my family to get
money and get rich i had that on my mind
every day i woke up and i strived as a
rapper i gotta get rich i gotta i gotta
make myself a millionaire i gotta do
this i gotta do that i gotta get i gotta
get these trains i need to go gold i
need to go platinum i got to be big so
that so i don't waste this opportunity i
got this with this record label and the
moment i uh once they got out this the
situation all that [ __ ] went with it
i let all that [ __ ] go when i let that
[ __ ] go you heard so
and the outcome just is amazing and it
still is amazing i'm still growing like
i got a long way to go from where i want
to be i got an extremely long way to go
like you look at a lot of
a lot of my peers in the rap game and i
ain't just seeing [ __ ] from detroit
just street artists over overall guys
that rap about the street his [ __ ]
really turn [ __ ] got 100 million
around this [ __ ] i got a long [ __ ]
way to go well also a lot of these guys
i mean
obviously you gotta you know up the
scores with dirk think about dirk's
journey man like dirk's journey's been
so long real grand real grind dirk was
kind of like a you know he was in the
drill scene he flew under the radar
forever never really a superstar and
then the last 24 months is just it's out
of here for him
craig you're going crazy right now like
that's a real grind right there that he
grinded for real
you know it's crazy
the same situation with him once he not
went with his label no more that's when
it happened yep same thing off as soon
as he got departed from his uh separated
from his life
soon as they separated that man took the
[ __ ] off that's some real [ __ ] um
how did
you know obviously up the score is like
you're i mean that [ __ ] is going crazy
yeah but it's time still still moving i
mean um
how did the dirk feature come to be like
like you guys have had a relationship
i'm assuming we ain't i know like no
friendship relationship type [ __ ] but i
always knew him you know he knew of me
it was just mutual respect just overall
just because being from where he from
from where i'm from you know like when i
did the song i just heard him on that
[ __ ] we reached out and that [ __ ] got
done with like within like a week did
you have to pay him for the future ah it
was just
like wow
that's big
that [ __ ] was all gangster i mean
now you owe him a feature
yeah for so long
you gotta do the trade now yeah now i
saw him but i mean money still was
involved no of course of course but it's
just off off of respect like when you
see a [ __ ] that big like that you know
what i'm saying like
you can run with some free [ __ ] you feel
me but it's like when you want the
business to be done and to be done
properly and i want to profit off of
this song you want to maximize the
potential of the song everyone's gotta
get situated so it's like man listen huh
[ __ ] that huh like yeah huh you get what
i'm saying but it wouldn't know like i
didn't have to pay for that verse at all
but as [ __ ] got done because of the
business part and just out of respect
like and they ain't no fool like i don't
think about just giving them a [ __ ]
song and you put it on itunes and you
maximizing out on this [ __ ] you getting
booked for shows off this [ __ ] and [ __ ]
just ain't getting nothing you know you
either one or two things gonna happen
that's that song ain't gonna get
supported or you feel me you gotta bless
that [ __ ] if you know what you see
i mean he blessed you back i saw you uh
you were on the i don't know how many
dates of the little baby dirt toy you're
on but i know you're on in phoenix right
for sure yeah yeah what what i mean
that's a big that's a big deal
yeah i i ain't doing it every day
because i'm you know i got so many shows
booked up but like if i if if this [ __ ]
would have came about before like all
them shows i could have did every single
date with you're doing spot dates on the
tour exactly the dates i'm available i
ain't gonna just cancel all of my
[ __ ] shows that's still my money yeah
that ain't a tour like i'm i ain't
getting paid
for that like i wouldn't even want no
that's opportunity it's opportunity what
i'm saying i wouldn't even go in those
situations like that ask for that
[ __ ] right right right let's
just get in front of all those fans
prices they don't even make you'll be uh
you'll
be a fool even yeah what i mean that
[ __ ] just sound dumb for sure feel me so
but at the same time i got to feed my
family mm-hmm making forty thousand and
so so i gotta get my you hurt so right
now
if a promoter hits you 40 40 racks
that's a concert what if somebody wants
you to come and do one song at the club
now how about this i'm gonna present it
this way
they want you to do one song in the club
but it's a market where you're lit
ah pop up a pop out come and do the
record at the dj booth yeah for half
you know what what's crazy is i
appreciate about you is like
i know that you know that it ain't like
that everywhere no it ain't so if it's
some random ass market where you're like
man i'm trying to get in front of some
new people i'm gonna do it for free
that's crazy i ain't gonna cap like to
this day like if i know i ain't turned
in the market i'm i'm not and i gotta be
in that [ __ ] i'm doing it for free if
it's a market where i'm lit at come on i
gotta mix
of course i can go get some money from
any promoter in this market but if it's
some [ __ ] where i ain't
[ __ ] ain't really hip to my
music i gotta go regardless so if it's
just this just speeding that process up
i just got a free flight to this
[ __ ] free travel free room yeah
bring my team go campaign in a new city
exactly i gotta do it free i don't think
like that i really don't move for money
bro i really don't
okay
i've been seeing you around qc a lot
seen you around p a lot
so um
you obviously dropped the record with
baby yeah
shout out to baby
um
i'm assuming
you just got out of a major situation
but with as hot as you are right now i'm
assuming that everyone's trying to try
to lure you back onto that side of the
game so absolutely everybody right that
means every label so
what's you know i'm sure qc might be an
option for you
you know is there is are are you
considering
going back on that side of the game man
we we're going we feel whatever have we
gone
that [ __ ] gonna pop out i would like to
just point out that there is one company
that you could sign with and get the
best of both worlds
and there's a bald palace uh a guy from
palestine named ghazi who i think is a
real [ __ ] i'm just saying i'm just
saying guys are real
guys are really solid let me tell you
something about guys we gotta get you on
empire bro all right we gotta kick it i
[ __ ] with guys dude man listen bro i'll
just text guys the other day that won't
[ __ ] hit me back yeah you know but me
i don't mean guys he texts his wife back
but it don't mean guys you know it's
crazy bro i knew gazi for like four
years we ain't never talked about no
business we had one conversation about
some business this was last
january we always text about just
regular [ __ ] like what's up hope all is
well you know yeah doing your thing it's
always regular conference we never text
about being i'm sure if i had to hit him
about some business he probably would
have eventually but you know it'd just
be regular [ __ ] but like one thing about
guys that man put a lot of opportunity
in detroit michigan he has literally he
did he did i can't ain't nobody can
nobody front that [ __ ] take that away
from him he did way more for detroit
than anybody on them as far as a museum
other than barry gordy that's some real
[ __ ] that's a fact can't any can't
nobody that's a fact and he's there a
lot like it ain't even about taps in but
i'm saying bottom line is barry gordy
and guys he did a lot for the detroit
music's culture period that's a fact
that's that's that's fair that ain't
even arguing that we can't even argue
that's not even up for debate and i'm
not with empire and that's not up for
debate i'm a real [ __ ] that's just the
truth that's some real [ __ ] man um all
right man look so obviously rich off
pints we know what that's about
uh
do you still sip is that something you
still participate in man from my own i
don't think y'all sibling [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i sell water man i was gonna say because
like i do feel like the tide is turning
to where at the very least
sip and lean
isn't
promoted and glorified as much as it was
as to where you know three four five
years ago if a rapper sipped lean you
would know about it cool too back then
like that [ __ ] drug that [ __ ] is
addicted i've really been addicted to
that [ __ ] like i don't withdraw from
that [ __ ]
you feel me like i don't withdraw it
around my old lady or fellain that [ __ ]
was embarrassing you heard like that
[ __ ] of drugs i don't suggest nobody's
drinking it ain't nothing cool about we
rap about it we rappers we hypocrites
[ __ ] i know i'm able to quit yeah
because i don't suggest [ __ ] doing a
lot of [ __ ] that i talk about but i rap
about what i've seen but you know what i
live what i've seen others do you know i
just don't say who i seen did it you
heard like this [ __ ] be all past tense
or at this point i feel like i'm
speaking for
i tell stories i tell stories that's
that's made up because i feel like i'm
speaking for people that's out there
living that [ __ ] but one thing about me
i'm always tell i'ma speak when i rap
i'll make songs every time i talk and it
seems like i'm glorified some uh some
some negative [ __ ] i'ma always speak on
the consequences that come with that
[ __ ] yeah i've been in the feds i've
been in prison i know what kind of ain't
no win what were the charges why did you
go to the feds i just got caught with a
gun
[ __ ] well you're on probation or
something and no just i'm a felon so
it's called felony possession
that's crazy i don't know like no major
indictment i had a one man kind of
diamond with nobody on my indictment
when it wasn't no [ __ ] like that
what you know for people who don't know
man because i've i've been around family
members who
not off a lean but off of opiates
trying to shake that [ __ ] going through
withdrawals having the pains in your
legs and [ __ ] like that not being able
to sleep what is the withdrawals from
lean feel like physically if you could
describe it it feel like the same thing
that [ __ ] of
any other drug go through like
every withdrawal is the same thing like
physical pain just
irritation [ __ ] like that like
feel like you got a cold type [ __ ] you
heard like that [ __ ] ain't it ain't
nothing cool it ain't nothing good it
ain't nothing not suggest it's just
you know that [ __ ] ain't that [ __ ] ain't
[ __ ] that [ __ ] ain't nothing nobody
needs to be doing that's fascinating i
gotta get money you feel me and live
long and seek knowledge like you gotta
feed that brain
you heard like i'm i'm a knowledge
addict now you do you read a lot i read
a lot extremely a lot my favorite author
is daniel silver i've grown to like him
when i was in uh the
in the joint you know it was when i was
reading his books i mean him write true
stories and [ __ ] like that but
it's just
the way where his books are everything i
was reading i was visioning that [ __ ] it
was like it was like your netflix in the
hole absolutely and then you know i
started getting into deeper books like
elijah mohammed mentioned to the black
man and i read the malcolm x book and i
just read i read a lot of books i read
obviously i
read the bible i read
everything i can get my hands on i seek
knowledge is that still the case like to
this day you still read a lot of
knowledge yeah you can go through my
youtube history right now you'll be
you'll be surprised bro
what's like the last random youtube
rabbit hole you dive down
like what did it have to do with let me
go check cause sometimes you know you'll
get on a youtube binge and you you'll
end up watching some [ __ ] you had no
intention on ever watching in your life
you're like wait what i get deep i go
deep bro
this [ __ ] seriously
i really seek knowledge
tell the people listen
tell the people what you see
re read what you see
biblical jesus
and islamic jesus
keep going
did jesus ever say that he is god the
early history the honorable elijah yeah
the lost tapes malcolm x keep going yeah
dick gregory and elijah muhammad what
malcolm x did not tell you
the final signs of dijjal's arrival are
here
plastic and cosmetic surgery i don't
know
no mo that's my wife that's my wife
kieran
that's my wife
she was sure
not for real
i got it when your wife started watching
[ __ ] and it was like makeup tutorials
i'm like this is probably not him i mean
my old lady we we rock like that like i
don't feel machine we rock like i just
had d smoke up here uh these smoke don't
go through my wife got my face on go
through my [ __ ] if she on instagram she
logging her account going answering she
on youtube she
don't go through my messages she don't
go through my car we really gangsters
like we really rock like that your wife
is not the type of person that if you
fall asleep boss no i shouldn't do that
[ __ ] boss for real that's beautiful she
don't ask on my phone she don't look at
my messages like she don't do none of
that [ __ ] like you know you know
yeah i think that that's how most i mean
that's how relationship should be
because if you are on that then why are
you together
if you can't trust somebody
because guess what if there is some [ __ ]
[ __ ] going on in a relationship it's
going to come to light eventually every
relationship is about trust whether it's
a friendship marriage
a relationship are you married
yeah i mean
it's crazy because i d smoke was up here
before you got to be married i got
children we had it how many kids you got
i got two i stopped man i got two kids
too i'm not married because just
you know because we had children i feel
like when i say we got to that's what
god i want
i work i'm a slave i was talking to uh
dee smoke he had a line on his new album
and he said my wife drove me to sanity
not to what he said my wife drove me to
sanity nothing drove
that's a fact you married bro yeah so
you you understand yeah
do you know how we would be moving if we
ain't had that backbone 100 we wouldn't
be able to do what we're doing i wasn't
married when i when i when i caught none
of my case
i went married and none of that [ __ ]
you heard like
none of that [ __ ] like
yo yo like your wife
every real man need a queen you gotta
had it you gotta have that backbone
like
you gotta had it that's that's balance
and that's that sanity and that's that
that's that um
you know your accountability
that's your accountability partner for
real yeah like your wife can hold you
accountable ain't nobody gonna tell the
truth like a woman or a child women and
kids they tell the truth ain't nothing
better than a woman's intuition every
time my wife told me a [ __ ] was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he was a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
what's crazy that's the same [ __ ] with
my girl my girl will tell me some [ __ ]
and then i won't listen and she's always
right i'm like man
yes it's crazy just like my mama it's
crazy how that is though whenever my
mama told me shane like one of my homies
she something happened and then i ain't
like i'm not moving
my mom ain't never been wrong about no
[ __ ] i ever brought around her my old
lady ain't never been wrong about not
one [ __ ] that i ever brought around her
at all is it harder to keep your team
and your circle smaller the bigger you
get
it make it easier for me you want to
know why why because [ __ ] always seem
like with money in like a position
or what
when people be on the out looking in
like you know us we we we we just live
in our life
i feel like people praise what you got
more than what you do
and it drive [ __ ] to always
just show their true colors and they cut
they self off
you know money revealed
money what was there the whole time
exactly right money revealed hate
you always do money bring the truth out
of people hey what up man we gotta
interrupt the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at odd socks
now when i be riding for odd socks so
hard man it's because i really love the
product they got the most comfortable
socks in the [ __ ] world i got a pair
of odd socks basics on right now go get
those they got the socks wwe joints see
what i'm saying shout out to the
undertaker pepsi [ __ ] really
whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapateo underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview
have you know i mean
you know there's obviously
something that's to be said about
getting more hate from where you come
from than anywhere else
is that something that happens with you
and is it something you even that bother
you with at this point
honestly like
when it comes like detroit
i haven't experienced that but you know
i'm sure it's like that
but i feel like i haven't experienced
that because i'm just i'm the same i'm
just me i'd be me
you know i'm the same person i am no
matter where i'm at like
i know it usually go like that i can say
this
it been times where
[ __ ] who i felt like was
supposed to support me didn't support me
until everybody else did
but when they kind of like
music and like my folks rocking my music
the same look i get everywhere else i
get it in detroit
just like saying hey i get everywhere
you know what i mean unless [ __ ] got
it but everybody got secret hate
questions like that [ __ ] is ever man
it's it's [ __ ] [ __ ] everywhere it's
hatred everywhere it's real [ __ ] j
where is jealousy it's all the same all
around you know what i'm saying i don't
even like to say i get i don't even like
using that terminology
you know love with love love don't live
where we you heard like my kids love me
yeah mama love me my family love me i
can't say nobody else love me i don't
have no proof for that love is action
that's some real [ __ ] that's true
that's a nice way of putting it um
you know building your relationship with
someone like p from qc what you know
he's somebody who has an executive has
you know uh
done some special things him and coach k
uh what is some game or maybe some
advice that that you have gotten from
your friendship with with would be a
real [ __ ] like
day one like but when me and pete first
linked up we ain't discuss
signing or you know me beings are it
wasn't never about that [ __ ] let me
straighten my eyes like bro you a
hustler you remind me of me like i like
how you move i want to show you how to
turn this [ __ ] up and do this [ __ ] next
level i want to show you the business i
i think you should you need to really
learn
the business
it was never about him sign a contract
put no game put no contract in my face
or email it to chanel it wasn't never
about none of that it was off top like
just a mutual respect like and that was
an honor to for a [ __ ] like that to
look at me like a hustler i look at bro
like ultimate hustler you heard so for
somebody to see what i was doing on such
a small level compared to what he doing
and and it meant something you know and
it counted for something not only did it
show me i'm doing the right thing and i
can keep going but it showed me how to
conduct myself as a boss like when you
get to a certain level you it ain't
nothing wrong with reaching back when
you see other [ __ ] just like you you
are if you see yourself in another [ __ ]
and
you got to show people the business
you heard like i don't got the
impression from other people that as
long as you know the business you are
right
but he changed my mentality on that he
showed me that now the right thing to do
is to teach people the business then do
business with them
yeah they'll do business with them and
then teach them the business
teaching the business then do business
with them
so i kicking my young [ __ ] hyundai
he from grand rapids you heard like he
not he with ice directs we don't even
have a contract
because i'm teaching him
the business
and then that's then he got to decide if
he gonna if we gonna rock if he gonna
sign a contract
hey man that's not the because that's
not how this [ __ ] typically works but i
won't be able to fool him i don't want
him i can't and you don't want him to be
able to sleep at night
you you want to sleep at night i want to
say it ain't even just that i gotta i
gotta look my son and i and tell him i
stood tall in every situation i was
silent with everybody i ever encountered
i ain't [ __ ] nobody over i ain't
misguiding nobody i mistreat nobody
everybody i ever
took took heed of what they said they
didn't mistreat me or misguide me
you heard so i wouldn't give out that
same energy and it's just it's just
gonna be solid like if every artist i
got with me
intelligent
on the business side
and morally
and they seeking the same knowledge
outside the muse that i see that's it
ain't go that's a powerful team
that's a strong fish now i feel like you
know qc is doing that i feel like god is
doing that you know what he's definitely
doing that yeah see that guy and it
don't talk about it just do that with it
he don't talk about it mm-hmm it's just
in his ass and they actions them to them
two [ __ ] that move actions
i mean you heard them things ain't doing
interviews talking about what they do
for artists their actions speak foreign
none of that [ __ ] their actions speak
effect 100
who else on the album oh i got pluto on
there
i got a babyface ray on there
rio de jango g on there
[ __ ] thank you free rio
man i got a rumor man me and rumor got a
song so hard well your cousin manages
rumors shout out to adrian swish the
legend [ __ ]
rumors are alien man dude dude so
[ __ ] he's so fired roman gonna
be big you gotta take off his [ __ ]
ski masks yeah for sure i ain't never
seen [ __ ]
ever
i'm like bro when you [ __ ] [ __ ] do
you wanna i know it [ __ ] like two-toned
probably at this like yeah i wouldn't be
surprised like
like what is going on bro like
man rumors gonna be big room are gonna
be bigger than a lot of a lot of i think
they're gonna be huge he's huge man um
you and babyface ray i mean obviously
babyface ray somebody coming out the
city who's are we from the same
[Music]
would you guys ever do like a collab
like ep we'd be talking about that [ __ ]
every time we see each other never get
it done we don't record it
fast songs and came up with a name and
everything like we was going to call it
this purple gang like that'd be crazy we
never it's just his [ __ ] it seemed like
our career started moving at the exact
same time for some reason so it just
been kind of making it a little
difficult but we definitely doing the
tape like who else
outside of detroit would you want to do
a tape with uh i feel like
me and pluto got good chemistry and it's
like as far as musically when you say
pluto in the future yeah yeah okay
definitely we would make some hard ass
so
i don't know why i'd love to hear you
and mozzie do some [ __ ]
hard i [ __ ] might be lonely that
[ __ ] hard yeah my i feel like you're
you and mazzy would be
a special that'd be a special little ep
why is it speed talk real [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah he moved like one two like and you
know what's crazy he's kind of the first
rapper that started that kicked the cup
[ __ ]
you know he started that [ __ ] 2017 he
was like the first guy to be like man i
can't do this [ __ ] no more kick the cup
i think we need to really make that [ __ ]
a movement bro
and you know what's crazy is if there's
a lot of [ __ ] bro that don't that
really respectfully that don't that
don't really be sipping like that
you know and they keep it a hundred
though like a [ __ ] ask when they don't
say i don't really be drinking like that
these [ __ ] just getting these getting
money and getting smart like that's
that's good that's a good thing the rap
game went like that in the 90s
[ __ ] getting money getting dumped they
was getting money and still getting
[ __ ] by the label they're still doing
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] smarting up y'all
[ __ ] going to the gym
all that [ __ ] like [ __ ] is just
moving like bosses it's a lot of nick
like outside of like
if you let if you let society and
instagram tell the rappers some of the
dumbest [ __ ] on earth
but realistically it's a lot of smart
[ __ ] bro like well because the the
people who are on the people who make
headlines on instagram at least at least
you know i always say there was like an
era in rap
2017 2018
where the dumb goofy antics was
dictating who labels signed right
we would see people that were getting
signed
i mean
just for doing
dumb dumb dumb ass [ __ ] on the gram and
they were putting music out with like
act like actual
dude it was that was probably one of the
roughest errors in music because i'd be
like we'd have people come up on the
show
and i'd be sitting across from some guy
nodding out
or who's got like no for sure
all longer [ __ ] faking this [ __ ]
this shit's still like wwf steve no it
still is it still is but it it was bad
it was bad bro
i mean you know you think of that that
was like the six nine era there was like
guys like there was just a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was like when little pump was
at his peak
just doing [ __ ] for the internet it was
like yo if you're known for your antics
and not your music first then you don't
got longevity longevity is not in your
cards this [ __ ] is in your heart you
know man i don't do i ain't with them
with none of that [ __ ] when you were
locked up man like
you know how hard was it
to
just deal with the time
like you said you read a lot right
what like meant like mentally you know i
know some people who come out of jail
and that [ __ ] breaks them
i know it takes their spirit i i mean i
know there's an answer that you would
expect because i know how i animate it
like rap rap [ __ ] is and how
fake gangster and fake tough [ __ ]
be
but this really from the heart it didn't
[ __ ] with me bro
because it made me better
i appreciated it that was the best thing
that ever happened to me
other than my children
it kind of put you on
made you think about like you said you
didn't know you had a lot to lose before
you you sat down that was the best thing
ever happened to me so my time wasn't
hard because i ain't you can make your
time hard for one i only had two years
that ain't no time
two it's just like
it's up to you what you deal with like
one of my home girls text me the other
day i'll show you the message it's true
style tell the truth
she said
she been hurt we was just having a
conversation like well i've been through
a lot i've been hurt a lot
and i told her i could have got hurt a
lot
she said how could you how what you mean
you could have got hurt a lot i told her
because the [ __ ] that was supposed to
hurt me i ain't let it
it's about what you let hurt you
so if you do a hard time that song that
means you doing hard times you know what
i'm saying yeah
you ain't got to do hard time that's for
nobody and nick i haven't seen [ __ ] in
that [ __ ] for 30 years and that [ __ ]
like they got four months because they
they mastered
they mastered their self up here they
master their mentality
they master their thoughts
you mentioned being in the hole is that
was that like a little harder to deal
with those times that's when i felt like
i was in jail 23 hours a day yeah before
and then i was in there in the
wintertime so we was on orange jumpsuits
with socks and sandals so i ain't go
outside and show zero below i was in
ohio so it was 24 hours a day [ __ ] oh i
did three months the first time and i
went back and did three months the
second time it was in the summer time so
i was going out i was doing two 23 hours
but
i didn't feel like i was in jail until i
went to the hole i think i had a cell
phone that [ __ ] i'm
just
i'm doing everything [ __ ]
you feel me so it was just it didn't
feel like jail what what what did you do
in jail to result you going to the hole
um i caught a cell phone contraband yeah
it's a honey serious shot
how does it someone get a cell phone in
jail man i can't do that brother
is it the guards
i'm not saying how do you get it i mean
in general i mean there's a someone
brings it in while visiting guards bring
it in they got they sister man it's a
lot of brothers still locked up you know
what i'm saying they i don't know
because i feel like
the the an underrated relationship right
because
i mean i've been to jail not for as long
as you
but
all my cousins hard prison time right
the relationship between the ceos and
the prisoners it's either
really bad or really good or it's like
they're your lifeline to the outsider
they could be or it's really like you
you know these people right but i always
wondered i always wondered if
ways of inmates ever rubbed off on cos
you get what i'm saying yeah they watch
us politic they watch and then they
gotta go home and they gotta go home
they got a whole life they got a world i
wonder if they ever dealt with
their personal life and use
you know some of the knowledge that we
that they watched us politic i wonder if
they ever felt wrong
in the situation
and they they reasoned it
was the same reason like we felt wrong
like what if they ever had a school they
homies like now you can't do this this
woman right like if any of the anything
yeah you get what i'm saying anything
good or bad rubs off on them in the real
in the real world i was wondering that
[ __ ] i don't i wonder if that because
they still people at the end you know
hey it's a job with benefits they're not
police yeah they're not that's wrong
when people get on ross because you see
them like that don't mean [ __ ] he wasn't
a cop you know what i'm saying
i i don't know man i think uh awesome
man yeah i think ross is uh
i was just with bernard we we just had
brenda here sunday and we're talking
about you know ross and just like
how much of a
inspiration he's got to be to everybody
if you're really paying attention
he found the trenches at the end of the
day you know and i don't know ross
personally i don't know what he
personally did in his life so i can't
speak for his character
you know what i'm saying but you could
speak it on an action
business yes
business-wise here boss that's that he
made it in the music industry you know
what i'm saying and he is from where he
from he's from dade county that [ __ ]
ain't no playground i missed the
trenches
what about um you say you have more
money than you've ever had are you
interested
what kind of investments are you trying
to make or what kind of things you're
trying to do with your money to try to
make sure if rap goes away tomorrow you
know it's still oh first and foremost
i'm paying my taxes
smart that's the first thing that's
that's how i'm gonna keep my money from
cause the irs will be on your head
absolutely so i'm paying you you wanna
get wesley sniped i bought a home
in my name with my credit
and um
i'm taking what i invest in slowly
because uh like i said i had
money prior
and i had a restaurant i bought a car
wash and i had a dispensary at the age
of 24.
you know what i'm saying that's big
yeah but uh but
nothing came out of it because i i was
in it for the wrong reason
not only did i rush into those
businesses
i got those businesses just to say i had
those businesses it's a flex you know i
got my own car i don't know i own a
hundred houses and no [ __ ] [ __ ] up
because with business come
responsibilities
responsibilities drain your pocket
yeah especially if you're not in a
position to
or you have you don't have the bandwidth
or the team to deal with 100 [ __ ]
houses so this for any [ __ ] that's
getting some money be strategic about
what you invest in
definitely be strategic
yeah nah i know the cannabis business
i'm not that i'm off probation
i'm extremely interested in that and
doing it the right way well now
in michigan it's recreational right
almost not there yet though almost so
it's still medical it's still medical
yeah oh okay okay okay
they passed it but you know it takes
some time well i know cookies is there
now i mean it's booming it seems like
the weed [ __ ] in michigan is booming
right now we been had dispensers before
this [ __ ] was even
you know all the way all like i feel
like we was one of the first states to
have dispensary spencer's literally like
i remember 2014 seeing dispensaries that
wasn't getting shut down and [ __ ] you
know it was just certain stipulations
but i know they did pass it to be
recreational
but as far as i'm concerned like it's
[ __ ] still not getting treated i mean
even like it's crazy to think like we
were in new york
the week after it became like okay
and it just felt weird because you know
you'd go to new york before and you're
having weed in new york it's [ __ ]
tough [ __ ] yeah
having a gun in new york is even worse
right but like you know
now everyone is you could just smoke
anywhere in new york and the cops
literally don't give a [ __ ] you be on
the [ __ ] corner on the sidewalk
blowing down a backwood
in front of the nypd and it's
that's hard it's insane ain't saying
[ __ ] smoke in front of the in front of
them folks
well they don't care man yeah i got a
gang of dispensaries out there it's
almost too much
it's it's very what like it's real
competitive yeah what happens is you
know people come from out of town and
they think [ __ ] is sweet and they come
to la and they think they're gonna get
on with some weed and then it's like bro
this is still
we're still in this number two biggest
market in the country still so much
politics involved out here especially on
the street level and furthermore it is
the most competitive legal marijuana
business in the world well that's the
real like that's really the stereotype
for l.a yeah i'm gonna go out there i'm
gonna get my packs
we're gonna go get some packs we'll ship
it back
like bro like you know make sure you get
you know you [ __ ] come out here
and also get robbed thinking they're
coming out here and you're listening
[ __ ] gotta stop this [ __ ] ain't sweet
at all not at all man right like a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] think l.a just like a land of
opportunity it's opportunity out here
but this [ __ ] political like i know real
street [ __ ] down here [ __ ] ain't a
lot of [ __ ] don't just like that like
[ __ ] coming down this [ __ ] and
just
you just off top just feel like
you heard you just gonna move how you
move all that and that's that's how i
should be anywhere i feel like that
about detroit i don't want nobody and
not that i own it i'm not you know and i
ain't saying like on the street
level like oh no you know no
no that type of [ __ ] just period just
just how i feel like
well this this this is somebody home
you get what i'm saying you still gotta
treat it like like you said somebody
you're not gonna go to someone's house
that you've never met before and
and and stuff put your feet on their
couch absolutely you should treat treat
that that's a perfect analogy yeah you
if you go to someone else's city man be
respectful
move the right way move the right way i
think that was kind of what happened
with uh you know with the no-fly zone
[ __ ] with trick trick essentially right
for sure like we all felt like that like
trick was just
the leader of that the the face of
he was the bigger artist yeah you know
what i'm saying so and he he coined that
phrase you know no flies
yeah man who in your opinion
give me your top five
excluding yourself mc's out of detroit
ever
top five mc's out of detroit
blade icewood
street lord one
cheddar boy malik
tough tone
man
i got i got a lot bro of course eminem
okay so you're putting m m in the five
i'm number one
top five in the world i mean i don't
disagree but i do know some people in
detroit are like i've never listened to
eminem in my life we love
eminem music it's just we feel a certain
way about
eminem
to a sense like
[ __ ] loving them like ain't nobody
ever tried eminem or he still living
detroit that's his home like it's our
home we just never met him
is that why you feel a certain way like
maybe he's not
touching the pavement like you know
you'd like him to maybe
i mean it ain't about what i would like
him to do his own man but
inspirational to us you know what i'm
saying like i'm accessible to the young
[ __ ] that's coming up in detroit i'm
gonna say i make myself accessible to
them i don't overextend you know i don't
just i'm not friendly i don't just give
right myself away but i still make
myself upset even even if i tell a young
[ __ ] bro you are that's all it be
taking to keep your [ __ ] going and
keep them on the streets
i mean to be fair i don't think eminem's
accessible to anyone
but come on bro we gotta we doing great
right no no no you're right you're right
that's why i thought it was dope to see
obviously sean worked with you
um but to see sean do that cypher at the
end of his album i i think it was was it
10 10 artists on there
how many articles on that 10 i don't
know i you know i never listened to that
song not once
but i just i mean at the end of the day
i think that was like a cool thing that
was some gangsta [ __ ] that was hard did
you feel any type of way him leaving you
off that no man sean got plenty of
record we got a relationship y'all got
records and a video together
he didn't put the hottest [ __ ] from
detroit on the song he put who he wanted
to
you know extend his arm to like you
gotta think the [ __ ] that's not on the
song as [ __ ] he already done
extending his arm to that shoulder to
popped out folk made a call for a [ __ ]
did a video with a [ __ ] did it sound
shine keep [ __ ] solid bro he do
he keeps it gangsta
i was slightly mad
about that because i know how big i am
in my city so yeah
i
like i'm not a [ __ ] that feel um what's
that word
i don't i can't even think of a word but
you're titled entitled i don't feel
entitled
i just know where i stand when my music
ain't doing good i know when it ain't
doing good i knew when my [ __ ] wouldn't
turn i never felt entitled i never but i
know what i know my value
but just
when we had a conversation about it i
understood exactly what he meant
and that's just what it was like i'm
trying to get everybody a chance yeah i
feel like he had kind of all walks of
like the detroit scene on there royce
was on there you know obviously
detroit's such a uh royce roy fired too
i mean royce
roy's one of the greatest of all time
in the world the worst voice is one of
the greatest to ever touch your mind
that's why it's hard to name top five
from detroit you got [ __ ] like royce
five nine you got
uh lives boys kdz made west stretch
money like
stretch money that [ __ ] really lyrical
body james like it's two minutes boldly
james is a beast exactly bro it's too
many people bro yeah yo would you ever
you know cause obviously uh
would you ever work on some like
production like you know cause we think
of detroit we think of also j dilla in
slum village and
and and a real a real serious boom back
backpack scene guys like guilty simpson
back in the day that's what it was black
milk all that [ __ ] right would you ever
[ __ ] with any of that production just to
try to bring the two worlds together for
sure i would
absolutely i would
most definitely
did you come up listening to like any
jay diller or any of that [ __ ] never
heard and i won jay dillason i genuinely
thought he was a producer i mean no i
mean even he is i mean he is but he also
rapped as jd you know you know uh i
never i'm not gonna fake i never listen
what about slum village like alzheimer's
it was on tv a lot so i had to listen to
i didn't listen to i'm not that's not my
style i didn't listen to backpack music
right i know royce can rap because
you know race race do well for himself
in the rap community he a person you
gonna hear his [ __ ] regardless he kind
of i follow royce he post [ __ ] and a way
a [ __ ] rap i'd just be amazed like but
no [ __ ] he's he's one of them once
that's not my style of music i don't
listen to that but i do like how you're
because you know i've talked to artists
who are on the other side of the corner
now we just don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
but at least you know you're you're like
yo i don't i'm not it's not my cup of
tea but i mean i respect it i'm scared
rapper i know good lyrics when i hear
that [ __ ] i just don't be knowing what
half that [ __ ]
i i don't for me sometimes
it it don't
it don't um
[Music]
they may feel we're not talking about
nothing right
not seeing
that side of music
say that we not talking about it we
literally feel like they not talking
about nothing because it'd be a bunch of
lyrics
and it it just to us it don't
lyrical spiritual miracle it just don't
like what is that what is it a mind so
what all right what did you just say
what what
what am i learning from that but the
people that listen to them they would
decipher them them verses and be like
[ __ ] he just said mm-hmm you heard like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] said that you ain't you
gotta listen to this [ __ ]
just like somebody that listens to our
music would decipher for them
like [ __ ] he just said this like he had
it hard he did he did you know and they
might understand it you feel me so i've
grown to not
downplay nobody something just because
it ain't your cup of tea
exactly or i might not understand it at
the time you just got to decipher it hey
listen gun your head if i had to ask you
the question who's your favorite rapper
of all time your favorite like your
personal favorite let's say you're going
back in the hole for two years and you
can only take one guy's [ __ ] cds with
you who would it be
jay
hey me that's a good choice for sure i
mean i know that's a lot of people's
choice but hey man it's true
hey what's your favorite jay-z album
blueprint the first one
and the dynasty
hey the dynasty soon you'll understand
it's one of them ones
that's [ __ ] and man stories just that
[ __ ] is remarkable yeah man it's
remarkable i think hove is like
dan tonchi
shout out to wayne wayne goat
he's he's he's he's up there and wayne
is a goat no he's up there he's a goat
for sure
he's up there up there bro no he's up
there he's up there
when you said wayne is the goat i said
no he's out okay okay he's up there yeah
i thought you said wayne is the ghost
and i was like yeah he's up there
no he's one of them names
you know you can throw
wayne hove nas
and you know all those people are in the
same
[ __ ] knives are the whole
story backwards rewind that's another
level it's another level of like [ __ ]
that's a level that still ain't been i
don't think anything yeah i'm doing that
[ __ ] bro hey man i'm doing that [ __ ]
watch
it right dude do it backwards i'm doing
that [ __ ] you don't hear i'm doing it on
my own
2021 street verse
what will it take for i swear vessel to
go back to signing to a major label or
is that even
possible anything possible when it makes
sense
absolutely anything in the world that
[ __ ] makes sense i need full
creative control and i need opportunity
for my artist
my artist got to be in a play
my manager got to get hired at the label
hey you gotta call them shots and i need
a contingency
plan i need to be a [ __ ] and or
when i'm done with this [ __ ]
hey that's right you know i know music
no i really say y'all just gotta make
sense
anything that you do has got to make
sense moving forward
and now you're in a position where
if it don't all right cool i'm doing me
i don't know [ __ ] i'm already rich so
this is what it is if i don't
if i never be able to get a plaque
it's all as well i can live through my
[ __ ]
how dope is it to have you've had some
records that
were dope in the club like regionally or
like certain cities like you know i'm
from phoenix so there's a lot of detroit
dope boys in phoenix so moon walk-in uh
the money phone these are all records
that i would always play in the club in
like 2015-16 right walk was my first big
song
no i mean technically money phone was
but that was just big
you know in my reason moonwalk was the
first song where i was in a whole nother
city doing some whole other [ __ ] and was
watching people rap this song word for
word and ain't taking out one picture
with me because
it was bigger than me ah well up the
score is like a record that again is
like yeah what they know is me though
yeah but i saw i saw um i think dirk
brought you out at college or something
[ __ ] me up that [ __ ] me up that
[ __ ] was crazy i don't even know it was
under ig i don't know what city that was
that wasn't um it was in uh it was in
illinois i just forgot what city it was
chicago but that's wild right like wake
me up that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up what is
that was that it was a mole was that a a
moment for you when you realized
absolutely wow it's working the first
moment that i actually realized that
this [ __ ] is working for me first moment
i had a long time
where i'm like this [ __ ] really work
that was that first moment yeah because
i saw that video i was like oh this is
that was that first moment yeah she
motivated me on a whole nother level
future how did your friendship with
future
begin like how did you guys get you know
get get to be close and obviously you
know what how is future i feel like we
don't you don't do interviews we just
kind of hear what we hear about him
and love his music yeah
uh my my little brother gt introduced me
now
she's just been loved for real like
i'm saying just regulating [ __ ] like
i feel like you're at a position right
now where
i could see drake just randomly
remixing uh i swear vezo song
without warning like free remix other
skull and not telling me that [ __ ] gonna
be too hard
any idea if he's like tapped in with
your [ __ ] at all i ain't gonna lie i
don't have no idea that like i don't
know
i don't even know i don't know
is would you do a remix to up the skull
like is that something you've been
considering or that's something i'm
considering it's coming
it's coming for sure it's coming
any uh anybody locked down
if it's gonna be one of the ones there's
gonna be one of them ones that is gonna
be one on one ask what's up man well
listen uh rich off pints too
it's out yeah i don't know by the time
this drops it'll be out now rich off
planes too out now y'all tap in with me
go look at all the videos subscribe to
my youtube channel
i swear veso i got a movie out too
called pricey love it's on amazon prime
and some uh did you produce the movie or
you started executive produced it i
wrote the movie and i'm starring in it
wow well i wrote i wrote them i didn't
physically write the script though but i
like the movie though yeah hating fool
[ __ ] mark smith shout out to kamal
smith
what was the inspiration behind doing
that man besides obviously i mean
there's some legendary underground
rounds
and i wrote that in the hole on some
milk currents wow because they threw my
rap book away so i thought i was
finessing my heart ain't gonna throw
these milk cards away wow they did a rap
book away throw that [ __ ] away that's
what i said yeah
ugh well listen man go get the project
um
and you want to shout out your artist
shout out to
81 hundo shout out to vano midwest
millie ceo chucky sbr peasy
richtown brother
sbr narco
uh
shout out to piggy she from cleveland
she's super turnt up shout out to
siddidi
you heard she from detroit she is she as
short as she turned to
man shout out to my manager though
chanel [ __ ] beast you know my cousin
adrian mj
and then shout out to everybody there it
is man i swear vezo
boom